[Music]  I'm Trish Z and I'm directing pitch  perfect 3 I want to take you around the  set and give you a little sneak peek of  what's coming  we're taking you on a global tour with  the fellas  girl what's a weakness nice [ __ ]  we're action stars here on the setup  page for victory  absolu getting attacked by dogs I'm also  allergic to so I going to be spending  the day idea we're almost exactly  halfway through our show right now there  are many people doing very important  things here in America we are not any of  them Anna campus hilarious no rebel and  Jon are just like peas in a pod and DJ  Khaled is amazing he's a force of nature  DJ cow will be in the big movie pitch  perfect 3 ok I am the most badass fellow  I mean I have to run at least 10 steps  and this same shooting kind of all day  so pretty emotional  [Music]  on my saliva melena United Center and  you go  [Music]  we're all gonna miss this it's been a  wild ride  [Music]  [Applause]  you  [Music]